oh one that crazy like what does that
mean i went crazy a little bit i think
it means that we do we like did things
that we
would never do if screaming and crying
like yeah did you smash anything did you
no no i didn't i don't i don't have that
in me no i just i just went like oh my
god i just felt like i went over like i
just went over there and just started
like screaming and like crying and just
being like what and then i got back from
a day later
i don't know in my head i like justified
it because he didn't actually like do it
that i know you know
that i know of so like in my head i was
like well he didn't actually like
like yeah like i don't know if he
actually was gonna do it and then like i
was like it could have just been like a
thought you know
i i'm not saying like that was smart or
wise but that's just the way i thought
about it so when i said crazy what were
you
um hmm
i look crazy what
um so i would say like no one heard that
go on um
like i literally like contacted him on
almost everything
and then just non-stop like calling
calling calling calling calling
then like basically when he did pick up
i was screaming at him i was like what
the [ __ ] do you think you're doing like
basically like you know i don't i feel
like like i would never
act like that normally i feel like yeah
anytime i act out of character i would
it's like say i'm acting crazy yeah
but that is your character then you
think so yeah because if if it's not in
you it can't come out of you
i guess
i mean
like do you not
so do not think that if like something
were to happen to you like you can
act some sort of way but
like you wouldn't normally act unless
you're in that you know specific
situation like you're just your emotions
are like to the max your stress levels
to the max like you know that it just
pushes you to a certain level i would
say i guess you could still say like i
acted how i would if i was in that
situation
[Music]
wow that's who i am yeah i think women
get to act crazy
you think we get to you get to act
there's more of a um
a leniency with you acting crazier than
midnight crazy because if a man acts
crazy it's like what the [ __ ] like
why [ __ ] i have dated an emotional night
like yeah but do you think that's do you
think that's because women are seen to
be these like emotional
creatures yeah yeah but but that's some
it's one of those double standards isn't
it because like i know women that have
like smashed people's cars
you know like done all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] and it's like women going crazy if
a man would smash a woman's car
like people be like oh my god this guy's
[ __ ] toxic he's like
you know what i mean like yeah you're
getting like
looked at in this in a different way
than women would yeah i agree with that
actually yeah i think girls are given
more of a past thing yeah
yeah i feel like that's like the there's
like a pro and con of being men or women
and so like you know obviously being
women i guess we get to be a little more
emotional whereas men they get to be
like more
what is it
um going
what what are you gonna say no i
i won't say that um women
aren't emotional but i think
men
are emotional it just shows a little
differently and i think the reason why
women may have a little bit more
leniency towards their emotion is
because
if a man is say if a man smashed
somebody's car the next thought that
they're going to think like what are
they going to do to me right it's just
like a fearful attack because we've seen
we haven't seen any women
um the first thing that comes to my mind
is football player in the states he
literally picked up this woman i don't
know if it was wife girlfriend or
whatever and like
drag like threw her across the room like
she was a rag doll
it's just like things like that i think
comes like to mind when a man
acts
their emotion is at that level to where
it's like crazy the thing is i've seen a
man do that to a woman but i've seen a
man do that to a woman
after she has
spat in his face
slapped him in his face
and been like what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do you can't do [ __ ] but what and
i'm like
just that physical action of him doing
that
will in the general public's eyes make
him seem like the bad guy and people
will kind of negate
what she done yeah do you know what i
mean like i'm saying women get to act
crazy and if a man responds to it it's
like oh look at him it's like did you
not see all the [ __ ]
what actually happened i don't i don't
like when women do that because i'm like
i don't like men hitting women
but it's like you've put yourself in
that position like if if a woman if you
did that to a woman she would react
retaliate the same way but you do that
to a man so when a man react retaliates
that same way you wouldn't be like you
shouldn't hit women well don't don't
give him that lead way to retaliate in
that way because you don't know what's
inside a person to put them in that
position
right
i agree
no one should be hitting anyone at all
do you guys agree with that
if you if you punch a guy like he can
punch you back yeah i mean i feel like
that's just like completely unfair if
like women are just like
i don't know what are they
supposed to just stand there like yeah
take it how are they supposed to process
their emotions like just sit there and
be like
and that's why that's why a lot of men
don't actually report domestic abuse
towards them
because they know it's not going to be
taken seriously it's like oh it's a
woman hit you what what were you going
to say it's like no but you know there
are a lot of women out here
out there
actually physically abusing men and men
are taking it because they kind of know
that
it's not going to be taken seriously
that does bring up like you know like
the johnny depp case
yeah what happened i don't know that
case so what's that actress's name
i forget her name but i remember the
recordings it was just like
yeah
she um
i think she was just like abusive
mentally and physically towards him
and i think she filed a case against him
being abusive towards her
but then i forget what exactly happened
but then obviously like he won the case
but when she was abusing him like you
could hear the recording she was like no
one's going to believe you anyway no
one's going to believe you they'll just
you know people are going to think did
he win he did okay and like i think
there were like some videos coming up
like where she would just like randomly
raise her hand and he'd like flinch
and it's oh man it's just so sad
it was her and not him but that's not
generally at all not him that's
generally believed though yeah do you
know what i mean it's generally believed
that it's going to be him he's going to
be the man that's going to be the abuser
there was a moment where he kind of got
blackballed in like the acting community
or whatever because people actually
believe that others yes exactly well
that's the thing i i feel like
when a girl accuses a guy of something
like people just automatically assume
like like what does it believe believe
all women believe all women but i'm like
some of these girls are crazy like you
can't you can't believe all girls i've
been i've been accused of hit of hitting
a woman really yeah i've been accused
what happened
um i've been accused of pushing a woman
down two flats of stairs
i had to go to court for it oh my god
i got found not guilty but it's just the
fact that
i was there you were there yeah there
was no injuries like what are you
talking about like we we may have had an
argument yeah right but
what
what are you talking about but because
women generally know they can call the
police and be believed
they have to investigate and i'm like
but so what was her evidence there
wasn't any
it was it was it was literally my word
against against hers
and so
yeah yeah
yeah i got found not guilty because they
had they undelivered they only
deliberated for like 10 minutes
and they were like
that's just so like disrespectful to
like all women that have been exactly
thankful
it's just like oh it's just so
disappointing
like for women to even have the courage
to stand up because it's very like
frowned upon on different like aspects
and it's so hard yeah it's hard it's so
hard as an individual to stand up and be
like this is what happened to me and
actually stand up again to prosecute
another person for what they did to you
and they don't get found guilty
because of women that do lie and
exaggerate their situation for their own
benefit
um and they do you know what i mean and
it just it looks bad on other women that
actually do get go for the thing it's
the reason why i can be accused like me
like okay i'm six foot two
i'm black yeah do you know what i mean
it's easy to believe that i am always
gonna be the aggressor you know what i
mean and so was it can i ask um what
race your
double black girl black there's a black
one young black woman yeah as a black
woman and so but but she's a woman and
so she's going to be believable women
right she's going to be believed right
and it's like well
if i have like no
history of abusing women and that this
just comes out of the blue for me i know
i'm like what are you talking about but
it doesn't matter that really doesn't
matter when they can't undo the
character assassination like there might
be people that like believe like there
was a case where a dude was um
he was
a girl said that she she was assaulted
by him and it came out that she lied but
like you can't undo everyone on campus
thinking he was a rapist for like oh
great gotta say great but like for um
great because you can't say
great
um for two years you know because or
however long the trial is
um
yeah that does
has there ever been a case where the guy
sues like the woman for
like defamation i don't know but i know
there was a case in america where
a woman said that um a guy graped her
[Music]
she um but it came to find out that she
dreamt it
was it was okay yeah she dreamt it but
he actually went to prison for it really
you went to prison for grape yeah but
how did they find out she jumped like
because i think afterwards like
afterwards he appealed and
have you heard of it yeah like she she
dreamt it did she actually believe it
happened to her though
i don't know i
i don't believe it i think i bet she
just knew they must have looked into her
psychology
she must have gone to psychiatric unit
she would have got evaluated if that was
the case
that would have been the procedure
do you think that she was like too far
like she started singing and she
realized it was a dream and she was like
too far in it and she couldn't she like
was too embarrassed to take i don't i
don't know but i think she should go to
jail i think any girl that like does
that should go to jail even if you
retract because you're like oh i'm sorry
like it was my mistake but remember
though when those kind of cases happen
we know the man
um you're right i don't know the woman
like everything is put out about the man
he's in the press he's in the papers
he's on social media he was accused of
this thing and it's like who's the woman
no one knows but i think nowadays
nowadays they do know who the woman is
because they do tell like both stories
but her her character is not
assassinated like his it's like a man if
if a man is accused of anything like
that he's finished it doesn't even
matter if he did it or not yes he's
finished but would you
couldn't you argue the other way where
they do
like say oh this woman like she does go
out drinking she likes to wear all this
and this she's like barely wears any
clothes wear high heels but it doesn't
mean you should be like well obviously
but i mean don't you wouldn't you say
like they're like what is it the media
is basically trying to blame the woman
yeah and that's and that's the thing
that's why when i hear
me personally when i hear that men have
been accused of something like this
i just wait for all the evidence to come
out i'm not saying he did it didn't do
it i'm not saying she's lying she's not
lying i'm just like let me just wait to
see but people generally there was a
case um in the uk last year there was a
woman um
i actually spoke about it there was a
old lady who killed her husband
right she was like penelope jackson
what's her name penelope jackson she
killed her husband and when the police
came
and because they had their body cameras
and they um they filmed it she was so
not she was like yeah he deserved it he
was an abuser and he done this and blah
blah and because she said that yeah
all the women just jumped to her defense
yeah she must have been going through so
much she must she she must have been
pushed to the edge come to find out when
it got to her jury she got 18 years for
killing him because she was lying but
the thing is is that it doesn't really
matter
it's the fact that she said it
and women just believed her yeah
and that's that do you know what i mean
that that's that and yeah you're you're
now guilty until you're proven innocent
when you when something like that
happens